[Music]
4:35 our bargaining unit block our pack
more down already
the most unique part of rally car racing
is if a regular person were to hear the
in-car audio of a driver and a co-driver
that would seem like they were being
different
in actuality it's a language that tells
that driver what is coming next
they really are just the eyes for the
driver before they can get to that spot
[Music]
rally car racing in America stage racing
that you can have anywhere from 12 to 14
stages anywhere from 6 to 20 miles in
some cases I mean you're racing other
competitors but really it's you against
the clock so inside of a rally car we
have two people we have a driver and a
co-driver the driver drives the car
tries to keep it on the road
without wrecking it and the co-driver is
responsible for reading the note 50 turn
a left 3 tighten right 3 - no cut so for
this example we have 50 here so that
means before the next no I call you'll
have 50 meters and then key for me
stands for turn which means you'll
change roads from the road that you're
currently on and then a left three left
obviously means your corners going to go
to the left and a three is the degree of
the corner there's so much information
to take in from the co-driver it's a 120
miles over a weekend
many two to three thousand different
commands that co-driver is reading the
driver it's pretty much that co-driver
is the computer of that car he or she is
going to get you from point A to point B
and as a driver you need to trust what
that tow driver is telling you we
started as a team when I was fifteen and
sometimes I feel like I can simply read
his mind I really trust what she is
telling me to the point where if I had
to close my eyes and maybe not drive it
race Beach she could tell me pacenotes
and I could still drive blind and trace
up
right before long night the right to
turn care bus retail
[Music]
rallies let me see how you know one of
my children has grown up and how they
become if I looked at her as a co-driver
and not a not a daughter or a relative I
I grabbed her
I love it make it a full-time career one
day and rally internationally and I'd
love you to follow my footsteps
you
[Music]